[Music]
let's talk about this there are these
big franchises now lego movie huh
yeah Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles movies
a lot of dough involved Arrested
Development yeah thank you
what I'm saying is we're at odds with
the audience and I are at odds with you
know I love the way the way that you
answer you ask me the question was a
good like a 1930s like P I you were like
the lego movie huh that's the skinny on
the street there aren't at look look
here O'Brien I'm gonna bust this joint
up put me through to Murray Hill two
three four you're on was to modernize I
got one of these no no no well I'm a lot
younger than you are
guys right looking just looking so so so
so my question is so do you have your
sights on other franchises does it help
when I act things out for you I'm not
stupid
[Laughter]
just the right choice of what to wear so
I would like to think I'd like to think
that I could be part of the Star Wars
phenomenal thank you think you could fit
into that whole francha I do I would I
want to I'm gunning for I want to be one
of the droids like a voice of one of the
droids because I feel like the droids
are pretty good but I would want to do a
droid this like more down-to-earth like
more relatable because like the droids
they've got all this technology they got
the spaceships and the Death Star's and
all this stuff and they still have like
beat EDD and we have to go like they
can't get a normal sounding voice for
you boy yeah yeah they can't do that why
don't they have it George is like hey
check it out over here we got some stuff
going on the way oh look out here come
the baddies
Hey hey guys get over hey fellas get
over here grab your stick balls have a
real punch up here so you know system
around the way guys
sure no girl from Brooklyn from Canarsie
up in here but we would have that or I
thought maybe why don't you do like I
could do one that would be much more
sort of authoritative use like maybe
like uh Oh looks like we got trouble
coming you know like a real like sort of
like a V like it just like a heavy sort
of announcer II kind of like does you
know it does sound like it would be cool
you know yeah you just he's just like uh
um guys chewing up your lightsabers
we're gonna have a real melee I don't
mean to accuse you of having like a
narrow range but that is the exact same
voice you use when you do when your
voice is in car commercials well I mean
that's not a bad idea
just like just has like a corporate
tie-in like guys we better get out of
here
Hey look there's a brand new 2016 GMC
Sierra
[Applause]
with room for six adults and a maximum
payload capacity I love it yeah right
want to buy one sure yeah talk to JJ
Abrams I got you in
I love JJ Abrams that was awkward we'll
take that did not flown at all that came
across as desperate and I get one more
shot at that yes oh that's funny JJ
Abrams I love that guy
[Applause]
we'll take a break much more with Will
Arnett in just a second
you